Hello, I'm Jan [inaudible]. I'm Robert
Krulwich, Radiolab. Our topic today,
parasites. Parasites. No, we've met them.
They were nice and we've met
them when they're not so nice.
I don't know that we've met any
nice ones really or we haven't.
I thought I thought that [inaudible]
Nice. Yeah, they were nice. So,
and now the question is,
let's just talk about scale.
I mean for the most part they're
irritating and Ludo and they seem kind of
invisible, visible and sort of offstage.
But when you back off a little
bit and consider them, you know,
in the effects that
they have on the world,
there are actually these powerful
sculptors of monumental narrative.
There was, these are little guys
telling very big stories. And Zach,
here's an example. Recently I went to
visit a guy named Dickson Despommier,
but Columbia University, he's eight.
There's intelligence and well,
there's a bunch of different things
we ended up talking about. Um,
well he told me this crazy story. The
story I love telling the most. Oh,
and before we start, I just want
to say one thing. The following.
Two stories contain moments
that are a little bit gross.
Just want to make sure you've been warned.
The story I love telling the most
is how we eradicated hookworm.
The story begins in
1908 John D Rockefeller,
Sr really rich guy's sitting in his
New York office and he's thinking,
how can I make more money selling
something to the south? Yeah,
I've got all this money.
You've got all these resources.
I just need a new market.
In terms of new markets,
the south was pretty much untapped if
only those damn southerners were just get
off their butts and get going.
Problem was, they weren't,
they weren't getting off there.
The forms were not operational.
The economic engine was turned off.
The economy was in the toilet. And so
John D Rockefeller wanted to know why,
why aren't they producing more? Yep.
What's happened to their economic engine?
So he thought, I know
all form of commission.
So he said that a bunch of economists
and sociologists and people like that on
the original Rockefeller Commission,
they did everything a commission could
possibly do to try to find out why these
southern gentlemen were not rising to
the occasion and they came back with the
following conclusion. Well, we
don't exactly know what's wrong,
but we think that these people are
sick from something cause they don't.
They don't behave like we do. What
does that mean? They are slow?
Not Mentally. They're slow. Physically.
They're Pale. I'll give you an example.
You remember the movie
deliverance short. Okay.
Remember that little guy
that played the Banjo?
I remember the other scene
that we all know we're not,
but if you can recall what that
little bed Joe player looked like,
why are we looking guy? But
he looked old, sickly pear,
simply pale and yet an adult.
Well that is not a description
of all southerners.
No description of in one
teeny corner in a no.
But what the commission did say about
a lot of the southern people that
encountered is that a lot of them, they
just don't look right. They look weak.
They look when they looked kind
of La man won one, they one hale,
lethargic. It's interesting
way in or one one future.
So the thought was that maybe these
southerners had some kind of laziness
disease. This is really
what a lot of folks thought.
The one member on the committee suggested
a Rockefeller like, you know what?
Perhaps these people are anemic, anemic
there. They're anemic. Do you
say, yeah, they're anemic.
It sounds like a medical problem.
Then maybe they're not lazy after all.
Maybe they're anemic and
maybe they're just waiting.
Okay, next thing you know, Rockefeller
puts together another commission,
this one with doctors
and he sends them back
down to the south to find out
what the basis for the anemia was.
And not only did they find anemia,
but they found a correlation of the
anemia was soil types. That's bizarre.
Sandy loamy soils, anemia,
hardpack clay soils. Hm.
No anemia. Sandy loamy swells,
good farmland, hardpack clay soils,
not such good farmland.
So all the rich farmers were anemic and
all the poor farmers were doing okay.
And this seemed to be a clue.
The incidence of anemia was
linked somehow to the soil.
Maybe bump a bum. Yeah.
Something was in the soil.
That's correct. So somehow they hit
upon this idea of looking for hookworm.
[inaudible]
the hook. Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, whoa.
all right, let's run some tests.
And when they did, big time,
they discovered hookworm big time. Okay.
Okay.
So the anemia is due to hook hookworm
[inaudible].
Now the question became,
how are these southerners getting the
hookworm and giving it to one another and
a pretty good place to
start to look for an answer.
Was there a feces because of
these silkworms or in you?
They're going to come out at
you when you go to the bathroom.
So they asked these southerners, when
you guys [inaudible] where do you do it?
Most of them said something
like this. I came over there.
You see a tree over there? That's right.
Deprecate. So I deprecate over there,
but I live over here.
Okay, so then the investigators
ask the next question.
When you go to that tree and do
it, do you, do you wear any shoes?
Most of them said no. Barefoot.
Just like everybody else
because it's comfortable.
So clearly these worms are in the feces
that are landing near the tree that are
somehow getting into people's feet the
next time they come to use the tree.
But no one intentionally
steps in their own, you know,
no one does that, which meant,
oh my goodness. Oh my
goodness, it can crawl,
right? So let's find out
how far it can crawl.
So what they did these researchers is
they built a sandbox and then they took
some hookworm infested stool
and put it right in the middle.
Then every day we'll sample from the
stool sample out in the sand in all
directions, and find larvae and
find out how far that can travel.
How's that sound?
So now we have larvae in the stool and
they began to crawl away from the stool
seeking a victim. On Day one,
they crawled an entire foot in all
directions, but they weren't a two feet.
On Day two, my God, they're at two feet.
At Day three, they're in three feet.
I can't believe it was the
crawling on a long way. Day Four,
they crawl to four feet. What about
day five? No, I'm allowed to ask that.
And what about day
five? Five feet? No, no.
Four feet. That's it. So after
four feet, they're what? Exhausted.
One would assume on day six
there were still at four feet.
And on day seven they were dead.
Yay. Yay.
So how in the world could you deal with
this problem when these worms can crawl?
They can crawl four feet. It
doesn't matter where your difficult,
they're going to crawl away from that.
And within a four foot radius of that
stool sample, you're going to get hookworm
unless you do something radical
that's never been done before.
They devised a scheme for burying the
stool sample into the ground six feet deep
because the worms can
only make it four feet.
Well then that's two feet past the
point where they die. We call that the,
so the outhouse was invented by exploring
the lifecycle of hookworm and in fact,
Rockefeller got his wish
the south did rise again.
That sounds too easy to me though.
You're telling me that, that uh,
an understanding of hookworm
which created the outhouse.
We removed the quote southern laziness
disease and they did rise with the,
and you, you bring that all back
to the hookworm? I do. Really, no,
I believe bring it back to
sanitation. Yeah, it'd be fair.
You can find plenty of other
reasons why the south rose again.
Air Conditioning and highways and
university, right, and stuff like that.
So though chrome had some help,
but what is clear is that when we as a
country began to distance ourselves from
our own excrement, to put it bluntly,
when we stop walking around in our own,
there were all of these
unintended concepts.
Salmonella disappeared is the Luda
disappeared. Shigella disappeared.
Colorado disappeared. GRD had disappeared.
Cryptosporidium anything that's associated
with parasites in feces disappeared.
Every time we build out houses
and people use them religiously,
guess what? Their kids can stay
in school. They could learn more.
They got ahead.
[inaudible]
Dixon, his mom. Yeah.
He is a professor of public health
in Environmental Health Sciences and
Microbiology at Columbia University.
Can they make longer
titles at the university?
Literally wrote the book on parasites.
The book is called Parasitic Diseases.
You know it very well. It's assumed
to be a major motion picture.
Now it's fourth edition
in its fourth edition.
And while we're on the
subject of hookworms and the
glorious campaign to Deworm
America,
because this has been a very carefully
crafted and intentionally fair program,
you have heard the case against hookworms.
Now let's turn the coin and say
something nice about hookworms.
And to begin that discussion, let's go
to our reporter Patrick Walters. Okay,
so pat, are you there? Are you
there? Yeah, I'm here, Robert.
So tell us a little bit about this
fellow. What's his name exactly?
His name is Jasper Lawrence, right?
Jasper Lawrence. So where is he from?
He actually grew up in England and
he grew up in this little farm in the
southwest corner of England.
Sorry. It's important to know,
I think before hearing any part of his
story that Jasper has had allergies for
pretty much his whole life
on really bad days.
My eyes would swell up so much from Poland
or airborne allergens that they would
feel like they were swelling shut. I could
feel my eyes squeaking in my sockets.
It was an enormously
uncomfortable feeling,
but it was nothing debilitating. They
were just allergies. So, you know,
he's just like, like most
other people have allergies.
Just learn to deal with it,
you know, you live with it. But
what changed for me in my late
twenties, early thirties, was my asthma.
And in that time I was living in Santa
Cruz. I was relatively recently married.
We had three cats, um, that had been
grandfathered in with the relationship.
And I started landscaping business. I
really didn't want to work for [inaudible]
someone else pick someone with allergies,
starting a landscaping business that
seems kind of unexpected, unexpected,
stupid is actually the word for it.
And uh, within six months or a year,
he starts to notice this
really weird barking cough.
Was there anything particular that
brought this on? Like, no, it would,
it was just sitting and breathing. Cat
certainly didn't help. Right. And uh,
during that period, my asthma got
much worse. Very, very quickly.
By the time it was 1996, 1997,
I was seeing specialists having skin
allergen tests and cycling through
emergency inhalers,
trying Singulair and all these other
drugs that were coming on the market.
I was being hospitalized, um, at least
a couple of times a year. I mean, I,
I looked terrible. I had dark
eyes and Pale, waxy skin.
I had that allergic look.
It was a really bad time and
he decides in that summer
of 2004 to take a vacation,
he made this visit to England.
Yeah.
I took my two daughters back to see my
aunt who had raised me very early in the
visit.
I was sitting at her table and she asked
me if I'd seen a BBC documentary about
parasites and their connection with
things like asthma and allergies and
multiple sclerosis.
And of course I hadn't,
but I went upstairs
and got on the Internet
after lunch and I've stayed on the
Internet until perhaps two in the morning.
I was reading and reading and the work
of all these researchers have been steady
after the neck, Japan and
epidemiological studies.
And African animal models and multiple
sclerosis, this enormous weight
of evidence that in the developing world,
people don't really have
asthma or allergies.
And what he discovers is
that behind all of this too,
his shock is,
oh, hookworms hookworm yeah,
yeah.
I learned that asthma was 50% less
likely in someone who had a hookworm
infections. So this sort of
just like hits you. Oh yeah.
What'd you think when you,
when you read that? Oh,
I immediately was determined to clean
hookworm immediately. I couldn't wait.
So hookworms are these very tiny worms,
the size of a little hair.
But if you take a microscope
and use zoom way in,
I have this big circular mouth
brimming full of pointy teeth.
Very scary to look at.
They have these toothy mouths so that
they can burrow up through your feet,
Grad through your blood,
and eventually end up down in your gut
and start chewing on the inside of your
intestines.
This guy wants aquariums in his
intestines. Absolutely. And so you,
did you just Google it? Yeah. Hook
Hook Worms for sale. I mean, you know,
someone's gotta be selling
them, but not, nothing.
I contacted every laboratory supply
company in the world and parasitology
research centers and they
all said the same thing.
No various flavors of no.
And so I came to the conclusion that I
was going to have to go to the tropics.
So fast forward, a little jasper
is in Cameroon along the coast,
quite literally and figuratively.
The armpit of Africa is 200 miles north
of the equator. It's extremely hot.
You find a guy to drive him around
and so he and his driver would go to a
village. You get out of the car,
walk up to these villagers and ask
them if they could see the latrine.
Just an open area of ground,
usually with bushes so people
can have a little bit of privacy.
And I would go over to the area,
remove my shoes and start walking.
The first time I did that,
I uh, I almost couldn't do it. It was,
it must've been 110 degrees that day.
100% humidity and the stench
and the noise from the insects,
it was so repulsive and so disgusting.
How many villages of the trains do you
think you've visited? Between 30 and 40
okay.
Jasper spent two weeks there walking
around in the village latrines and then he
flew home. Hm.
Yeah. I got back from
Africa in early February,
so I was looking at allergy season coming
up and the day I realized that I no
longer had allergies.
I was such a good day.
I got into my car and I started driving
and I had the window down and I felt the
breeze blowing across my face in the past.
What that meant was that very quickly
my eyes would be itching uncontrollably,
snot and s phlegm was going to be pouring
out of every orifice in my face and it
didn't happen. It didn't happen.
I just started screaming in
the car. I was so, so happy
and I didn't have an, I had an
asthma attack since I went to Africa.
I no longer have allergies.
The vast majority of the benefits that
I've experienced has come from hookworm.
Yep.
What, what is the hookworm
doing? Do you know?
Also the immune system that we learned
about in elementary school is all about
like these attacks cells, they go after
foreign invaders and destroy them,
right? And that's a big important
part of the immune system.
But if the immune system were allowed
to attack and destroy things unchecked,
it could kill you.
And there are lots of diseases where
the primary symptoms are caused by the
immune system attacking the body
that it's really designed to protect.
Allergies and asthma
are just two of these.
Some of the more serious ones are like
type one diabetes, multiple sclerosis,
Crohn's disease in which the immune system
actually starts attacking the inside
of the intestines. They are like
80 FTSE disease, 80 of them.
And so what scientists have found in lots
and lots of mouse studies and in some
human studies to this point too,
is that once the hookworms get inside
the gut and the immune system actually
starts attacking,
somehow hook rooms actually
stimulate the cells,
which just quiet things down,
nobody
and tell the attack
cells to stop attacking.
[inaudible]
so these are like lullaby
sells Jackley what?
Lots and lots of scientists
think Joel Weinstein stock,
Tufts Medical Center and dozens of others
is that over thousands and thousands
of years hookworms almost developed
in tandem with the human immune system
coevolution parasites living within
your body, your immune system changes.
He got to a point where the
hookworms could survive safely.
Worm gets a home is food coming down
the food pipe and in return the human
immune system gained some kind of some
form of positive regulatory advantage
[inaudible]
so that if you had this glitch where your
immune systems started attacking your
own body, the presence of the
hookworms would keep things controlled.
That's the gift. You do something for the
worm, the worm does something for you.
So then by that logic,
what we in the West and the richer
countries have done stupidly as we have
cleaned ourselves up too much and we
don't have enough worm easy on us. Yeah.
This is called, they called
the hygiene hypothesis,
the hygiene IP that we're
not dirty enough to clean.
We function like rainforests where
ecosystems and we've entirely eliminated a
class of organism that coevolved with
us and or genetic predecessors for
millions of years.
Now, I don't want to leave the
impression that hygiene is bad for you.
People can't go back to living in filth,
kids playing and sewage by the river
bank. But in improving our hygiene,
we are also excluding organisms that
may be important for making a swell.
So then what does Jasper
do about all this?
He decides to start a business
selling hookworm to people.
What you can call him up
and he will literally FedEx
a dose of hookworms to your
door. How I break in for a second.
Fat I jad where does he get the
hook and from, this is weird.
Jasper gets the hookworm from himself.
Could you describe how you go
about getting hookworm from,
uh, your stool into, uh,
one of your patients?
Well, it's a very easy organism
to work with. It, it just,
it gets up when it walks out of it.
So it doesn't take an enormous amount
of work to separate it from the feces.
And then I haven't done that.
I repeatedly wash them in solutions of
antibiotics to make sure that anything
that could live on them is
killed. People contact us,
we'll have them complete a questionnaire,
submit a recent blood tests,
then we'll ship them a dose and all
the materials and equipment and the
instructions necessary to infect
themselves. Two ways. Is this the same
freeing to do Jasper? Yes. Jasper
has done tons and tons of research,
but he's not a doctor. The treatment
is not approved by the FDA.
And I wonder is there any serious sort
of double blind study trying to figure
out whether some safe delivery of
hookworm might make sense? Yes.
And so one of the guys who was sort of
a pioneer in this hookworm research is
David Pritchard.
I'm professor David Preciado immunologist
and Paris fetologist up the University
of Nottingham where I study parasites
and the wound healing properties of
maggots. So we've now got two
safety trials under our belts,
but we've yet to conduct the trials to
show that therapeutic benefit results
from infection with words.
So Pritchard infected himself pretty
much just to make sure that we're safe.
What we did was 10 of us in the
lab took worms at different doses.
We were either given 10 25 50 or a hundred
worms and then we have to report on
the symptoms. Along
the back of that study,
we determined the 10 wounds
were tolerated by it. Richard,
when he did this, proof of safety study
actually gave himself 50 hookworms. Oh.
Which put him out of commission
for Awhile. I felt pretty bad.
I mean pain in the gut really, you know,
you can feel them cause they
are biting on your tissues.
I mean if you have too many hookworms
they can cause things like diarrhea and
the most serious side effect and the
side effect that makes them a sort of a
public health enemy is that
they can give you an email
[inaudible]
so if you have too many you, you lose
quite a bit of blood to these parasites.
Well, you know, if you
take too many hookworm,
which you're not gonna if you come to us,
the worst thing you're
going to get is anemia.
But it's not like you wake up one
morning and you're drained to blood.
[inaudible]
very slow to develop and
it's very easy to deal with.
Jasper is kind of just
gone for it, you know?
It's a very sort of like cowboy
move to the scientific community.
I think they believe that I'm premature.
It's not FDA approved and
offering this to the public.
You don't know what it is. You don't
know its purity. It's not safe.
But I've talked to several clients who
had really severe allergies and asthma.
They say they've just achieved these
great results and Jesper also says he had
seen success with that with a few
multiple sclerosis patients and several
crumbs. Do these patients too,
like how many people do you
think that you have infected?
It's about 85 right now. How is
business isn't everything that
businesses is adequate,
but I honestly don't know why I don't
wake up in the morning with my front
garden 20 deep with people with ulcerative
colitis, Crohn's disease, allergies.
I just don't know why I'm not
completely buried the way he sees it.
People are scared. Well,
they're the people who are coming from
a point of view of what I learned in
kindergarten about clean drinking
water and sewers to them.
Worms and parasites are so repulsive that
there's nothing good to be said about
them, but I can make you
better. It's simple. It's cheap.
I mean, for God's sake,
these organisms fall out my rear end
every day a half a million at a time.
The raw material is human
excrement for God's sake.
No.
All people have to do is open their minds.
Are you really that
scared of a little warm
[inaudible] [inaudible]
thanks to reporter Pat Walters and to
Jasper Lawrence and to the worms and to
look. I'm, thank you. Hookworms thank you.
Hope for more information
about hookworms on our website,
and that's the end of this
section with clean up the address.
radiolab.org yes. Slash
no [inaudible] dot org.